from investigating underwater murders to
shredding illegal fruits these staunch
detectives act behind the scenes to
solve some of the world's most unusual
crimes the Secret Service is more than
black sunglasses earpieces and two-piece
suits they're also an elite team of
investigators solving some of the
nation's biggest crimes sometimes using
nothing more than a blot of ink here we
are the lobby of the Secret Service
these were the only authorized shots we
could get upstairs in the lab we got to
see all the high-tech machines analysts
use in forensic investigations they have
names with things like 8,000 after them
so you know they're complicated did you
film a printer I did the lab includes
people like Trista who specializes in
handwriting analysis to investigate
threat letters or ransom notes Jeffery
investigates fraudulent items like IDs
traveler's checks credit cards and Irina
she works in the International Inc
library my name is Irina Guymon I am a
document analyst with the United States
Secret Service the Secret Service has
the largest ink library in the world
there are over 12,000 inks are currently
in collection this includes pens bottled
ink and printer cartridges basically
this team of scientists is using ink to
help solve crimes their ink vestigators
no don't do that
okay so here's an example someone writes
a threatening letter to the president
Irina will sample that ink and then
compare it to her collection exactly she
can figure out what kind of ink was used
and hopefully it helps solve the case
here's another ink sample no give me
that script the most counterfeited
banknotes within the United States is
$20 and it's printed with ink up which
means somebody takes they're very simple
at home printer and decides to print
money Irina can compare the counterfeit
currency to any printers found at the
scene of the crime and help make a match
okay time for a little science here's
what you need 12,000 samples of let's be
honest mostly black ink a lot of the
black inks and they're just black
they're actually a collection of
different color components that could be
a blues and reds and yellows maybe a
little bit of green Irena Ken for lack
of a better term sequins black ink
liquid DNA and find the exact breakdown
of color that's how she can make a match
so what appear is black at a first
glance is actually extremely different
on the inside and it's really fun as a
chemist to be able to take the ink apart
and see how it's made
I'm a nerd at heart I love the chemistry
oven I love the mystery of salvation
case I just really love what I do so it
may not look exactly like it's on TV but
it's really fun to be in a lab and to be
able to do any analysis and to be able
to help and assist all the
law-enforcement agencies that I work
with daily so Irina can you give us any
more examples it's on a need-to-know
basis and you did not need to know well
it looks like this case is all dried up
I've been threatening by Haiti with
Voodoo over food I've taken mangoes from
passengers from Jamaica and been
threatened with my life
never a dull moment here at JFK make it
easier that's it the reason why we're
confiscating all this stuff is not
because it's harmful to the human being
it's harmful for our plants and our
animals this is a big port last month we
processed a 1.5 million passengers you
figure between fruits and vegetables
we're talking about two or three hundred
kilos a day in just one terminal so
you're talking about four to six hundred
pounds what kind of foods are you
confiscating every day is different
every season is different Chinese New
Year Christmas Easter we have beef candy
from China serrano ham from Spain we
have lots of avocados salami from Italy
no Pedro I take the back so let mr.
primo that's Spain Spain also once the
food item is seized it's put in what we
call the contraband bin we drag a
contraband being across the terminal
it's about a block long get a little
exercise and begin the process of
grinding up all the prohibited food
items we're at the grinder table that
officer will look and see if there's any
little exit holes entry holes and that's
what you're gonna find the insect do you
enjoy that part of the process is it
kind of a stress reliever for you of the
grinders great sometimes they go home
with a little bit of mango juice and
passion fruit juice on it just happened
fun the water splashing in your face but
this is what we have to do to protect
American agriculture is part of our job
[Music]
there's a crime detectives follow the
clues they get close but then they reach
the water so they call in the underwater
criminal investigator that's Mike berry
hold on this is Mike berry I dive in
very strange places looking for very
strange things
Mike has been an underwater criminal
investigator for 35 years how easy is it
to get rid of a murder weapon all it is
is a flick of the wrist and someone's
mind that murder weapon is forever gone
they have no idea there are people like
me crazy enough to go down here search
law enforcement depends on guys like
Mike to preserve and recover evidence
your three cores in underwater Criminal
Investigation is body recovery vehicle
recovery and evidence recovery I get
called about twice a week sometimes more
sometimes less and when a call comes in
chances are Mike's in for a challenge
some of these locations are absolutely
disgusting our typical dive site is dark
it's deep it's cold it's full of
obstructions it's contaminated the
danger is there when you get in the
water you know I've had murderers tell
me you know you'll never find it
I said well we'll see there's nothing
like finding the target when your hand
hits it and you feel it and you realize
you've got it for a public safety diver
there's no greater thing and when he's
out there searching for a body I look at
it as an honor because you realize the
importance of what you're asked to do
there's a family and there's no closure
until you bring them up you know not
every diver can do this not everybody
has it in their DNA it's what I was
meant to do I couldn't think of anything
better to do with my life truth is I
can't wait for the name
all to help someone in some way either
to bring closure or to bring a
conviction fancy going shopping no no no
wish live in the Burlington Arcade who
you we are to Berlin some Beatles
probably the oldest and smallest police
force in the world you could say that we
police your manners right okay
tell us your story the beetle story
starts before we get into that what
actually is a beetle to be honest with
you I think anybody really knows we
predates any police force in the country
right back to the story
go ahead mark the beetle story started
at this arcade okay
and it games you know so it's just like
a shopping center right yes okay third
time lucky
go ahead mark the beetle story started
on the 28th of March 18 19
London was very different people didn't
really trust the water so they drank
even gin
oh yeah and obviously that Lisa was so
startled behind you
so the Beatles role really was to keep
all the within the arcade and in fact
that tradition has carried on right away
for you to buy our uniforms are made up
of several different layers we first of
all put on our way Scouts in our frog
pose announce our pants from the summer
or the autumn in the winter you will
still put on your waist coat you will
then put on your cape and you're sort of
half the original rule was here were no
whistling because the pig pockets would
whistle signals to one another no
drunkenness play a musical instrument
you're not suppose to hurry
some gents unlike an unladylike carry
your own parcels do you mustn't bring a
bicycle and the company ladies by the
way weren't all
allow them a lot of those rules we
couldn't be enforced it we still try to
enforce them they hurried in we still
try to enforce the low wisdom it's all
about behavior as long as you're
respecting those around you and
respecting the arcade you'll be left
alone and I put this uniform on I
represent nearly 200 years worth of
history makes me immensely proud yeah
when I say it's a no attire if I'm one
in spirit that's actually true but it
isn't just the you know the spill these
are sea turtle eggs and there are two
ways this situation can play out there's
either or there's so how can we make
sure this doesn't end up like this
well take a look again these aren't your
ordinary sea turtle eggs these eggs
could one day take down an entire
poaching network the story of these eggs
starts in Ann Arbor Michigan hi I'm Kim
Williams Qian and I am a conservation
ecologist Kim does research on a wide
variety of animals but we're here to
talk about endangered and threatened sea
turtles with sea turtles in Central
America there's an issue of poaching of
the nests for consumption of the eggs
and so her team has developed a unique
solution to gather more information
about the poaching trade fake eggs with
GPS trackers we can hide these fake
turtle eggs in sea turtle nests our hope
is that these eggs will get poached
along with the others and transmit
information on their locations where is
it that they go after they're taken from
the beach but for this to work the fake
eggs have to be convincing they have to
have the right feel because sea turtle
eggs are kind of a little soft and
squishy they're not like chicken eggs
we've been using a 3d printer and a kind
of flexible plastic but they still don't
look quite right and this is when our
story moves to Los Angeles
hello I'm Lauren and Lauren works in
Hollywood my day to day job as I work on
set as a makeup artist which could be
beauty makeup prosthetics creature
design wigs blood so it made sense for
Lauren to help Kim make fake eggs we
needed these eggs to look realistic feel
realistic and so that's kind of where
I've come in it was like the best way
that I could use my skills making
prosthetics but to actually like help a
whole species of turtles this is like
it's a dream job after months of
revisions it's time to put these eggs to
the test
in Costa Rica hi again you remember Kim
she's here to deploy the eggs herself on
a protected conservation area this is a
place that's very special because it's a
very important nesting site
[Music]
tonight a sea turtle will come and I can
test out putting the false sea turtle
eggs in the nest
not only will this project provide Kim's
team with valuable information on
poaching she and Lauren hope it will
inspire others as well
wildlife poaching can be abstract or too
depressing to even think about something
about this project kind of captures
people's attention here's this very
simple unique solution that I think then
serves as a jumping off point for
people's imaginations to learn more
about this trade all of us working on
this project are just doing it in our
our weird little nooks and wherever we
can and it just goes to show there's so
many little ways that everyone can help
you don't have to be making fake turtle
eggs to make a difference you can make a
difference in your own way
you
[Music]